somebody who knows about just keeping it
simple you give them the ball and
running
that's it let him run it let him hit the
let his hit his head on the goal post
like he did from some 90 yards out in
the regular season
and he's a tampa bay buccaneer super
bowl champion here courtesy of michelob
ultra he's ronald jones how are you
ronald
well great how you doing you know what
i'm saying just keep things simple you
know what i'm seeing
yeah do i ask definitely do i ask you
about national pizza day right off the
bat or
or the super bowl what do you think yeah
we can get into that it's up to you man
ask him a poll question chris brockman
all right ronald it's national pizza day
what do you put as your one topping on
your pizza more cheese
more cheese pepperoni sausage mushroom
yeah no mushrooms for me i'm growing
pepperoni all day though
why is that uh
i just like you know the pepperonis how
it feels you know or maybe some meat
lovers in there and you know
uh cracker mitchell oprah oh
yeah look at you working the sponsor in
like a veteran well done look at you
well done
look at you life's good isn't it right
now life's good
most definitely how does it feel
it feels you know sensational honestly
you know the weather i think the sun is
shining a little
uh brighter out here you know in florida
and uh
yeah i'm just soaking it all in right
now you're a super bowl champion ronald
jones
you're gonna get a ring that's that's it
this is that's
the proverbial nobody could ever take
that away from you that's a dream come
true i imagine
most definitely you know just such a
surreal feeling and uh just to be you
know the bunch that we had you know to
be out there you know and help uh you
know my teammates get there first and
you know brady seventh you know it's
just
uh yeah i can't even put it into words
you know how we're feeling
you know the kind of years been and just
everything coming together you know
uh definitely you know it was destined
so walk me through the first time you uh
you and tom brady met
when he came on board walk me through
that first chit chat yeah it's crazy uh
it was actually at you know berkeley uh
prep high school
we were having uh some some little throw
around sessions and things like that and
you know he just walked up and said hey
you know i'm tom brady you know i'm
gonna be a new quarterback yada yada
you know the rest of history so that's
kind of how it works what he said
hi i'm tom brady i'm going to be your
quarterback literally that's what he
said yeah
yeah like like i didn't know who the guy
was
we just got it in you know we were out
there for hours and immediately from
day one i could see you know just how
much it meant to him and
even though we were in you know no
helmets no pads nothing
it's still the same intensity that he
took to the field so uh yeah he's really
great
walk me through that put a little more
meat on those bones like a meat lover's
pizza put a little bit more meat on it
um ronald by what do you mean where you
realized how quickly
what it how how much it meant to him
what do you mean by that just like uh
yeah even when we were you know just
doing our little training sessions that
you know
uh you know a lot of people think he's
you know our business and stuff but
i think the moments that of joy that we
have you know
off the field with family and things are
just supporting us the hard work you
know
and we win because we're happy so i
think that
stuff just went hand-in-hand ronald
jones here on the rich eisen show
uh let's get into the running backs room
uh as well what was it like to have
lashon mccoy
right by your side the entire season
ronald
yeah that that was great too you know i
was literally showing him
i was watching his highlights and you
know high school and college and
uh never thought you know i'd be able to
share backfield with him so
but when he came you know i was happy
and i was able to learn from him and
progress my game as well
and uh play off lenny as he's referred
to so
um how how how about when fournette came
because obviously that that made things
maybe a little bit more crowded
for you as well how did that all work
together
ronald yeah i think it worked great you
know with a hell of a one-two punch and
uh yeah i also wanted to learn from him
too you know he had playoff experience
and
uh he's helped me diagnose defense and
stuff like that so definitely yeah just
competitive atmosphere in the room and i
think it
you know just drove everybody's uh you
know
game to the top can we start a nickname
play off ronnie for you
would you like that or no or is that
just too derivative
yeah yeah y'all call me super
okay super bowl rojo
i like it i like it a lot uh give me a
good aryan story
um people who i've interviewed for years
uh from his time with pittsburgh and
indianapolis and
also arizona tell stories about how he
will just
absolutely undress you verbally uh if
necessary because he just tells it like
it is you got a good story about your
now super bowl winning head coach
that you can share about that ronal uh
yes most definitely uh
i remember you know my first year uh
when they joined the team
you know you just told me you know uh
four or more you know don't come back to
the huddle if you don't get four yards
of pop and things like that
and you know he's just been a great
motivator and always believed in me
since day one so
you know i appreciate him uh having the
fame with me
and you know riding with me he told you
he told you not to come back to the
huddle unless you've gained four yards
like it's a four yard yeah he would
always say four or more you know just
things like that because
you know i was always looking for the
home run hit and uh
you know he was like to be a good
running back in this league is you know
all about consistency so
i guess that was the message there
ronald jones here on the rich eisen show
couple more things outside of your world
i'm sure you're hearing a lot about sam
darnold and being in new york and
all of that sort of business so uh i'm
i'm wondering about
what do you do you have any contact with
him do you talk with him or do you have
any any sort of relationship with him
that you could pass along or anything of
that nature
yeah yeah after my boy uh we communicate
you know every now and then but
uh yeah i don't know you know too much
about the situation but i just know that
you know he's a hard working guy and you
know wherever he ends up and you know
where he stays whatever i know they're
gonna get a you know dynamic player in
no i just took a stab yeah i just took a
stab that you might be in contact with
him because the number of people and
i'll be honest with you i'm a new yorker
and i was talking about trevor lawrence
all year long and now deshawn watson
might be out there
just how he might be handling all of
this like he seems like he's built
he's built to let this stuff roll off
i'm just wondering if you've had any
conversations with them on that front
at all oh yeah i have not yet to this
point okay well you got your own thing
going on what do you got going on with
michelob ultra
walk me through that yeah
uh i don't know if y'all thought of
commercial but the the commercial was on
point you know
it just uh the moments of joy off the
field like the time i spent with my
family you know
drinking mitchell over ultra at at the
beach and thing like that
just uh you know it's just important as
the work you put in off the field
okay so again um you're gonna be
um doing stuff with michelob ultra
throughout the off season this is good
stuff man hey
when is the parade have you been told
anything about this about any of the
post celebration or
anything like that yeah i have not got
word on the parade yet but i'll be
having a few more
adult beverages there too as well okay
very good that's looking like a fun time
for us
but in the meantime it's party at
brady's house right everybody going over
today's most definitely
yeah okay no no more no more no more
studying
right now okay congratulations ronald um
you know again i'm sure growing up in
you know in georgia where you did and
then you go to usc this is the sort of
this is the sort of dream to come true
right at your super bowl championship so
enjoy it
yes sir you got it there's a super bowl
rojo courtesy of michelob ultra right
here
on the rich eisen show